yeah well we can't get we can't let the
literalists get away with the notion
that their understanding of a sentence
is right
that just isn't how a text works it's
way more complicated than that and
that's a big problem because it opens up
the specter of infinite interpretations
which is the post-modernist dilemma
but
but saying the text has no meaning or
any meaning is no solution to that it's
like saying life has any meaning or no
meaning it's a problem especially when
they say their understanding is right
and they have the right to dominate the
state and they have to impose that on
everybody else so that's the that's the
key problem we have
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to have
as my guest mustafa akul
he is a senior fellow at the cato
institute where he focuses on the
intersection between public policy islam
and modernity since 2013 he's also been
a frequent opinion writer for the new
york times covering politics and
religion in the muslim world
he is the author of several books
including the most recent reopening
muslim minds a return
to reason freedom and tolerance 2021
why i as a muslim
sorry why as a muslim i defend liberty
which is also 2021 the islamic jesus how
the king of the jews became a prophet of
the muslims 2017 and islam without
extremes a muslim case for liberty
liberty 2011.
his books have been translated into many
languages and praised in the new york
times wall street journal the chicago
tribune the economist the financial
times and many publications across the
muslim world
meanwhile islam without extremes was
banned in malaysia for challenging the
authority of the religion police so to
speak
the thinking muslim a popular podcast
recently defined accola as probably the
most notable muslim modernist and
reformer so that's really something and
in july 2021 prospect magazine in the uk
listed him among the world's top 50
thinkers and that's quite the pinnacle
he's been thinking about the problems of
making peace in the modern world for a
very long time and stressing the need
for a liberalization in the islamic
world and perhaps some modification on
the christian side as well along the
lines at least of what happened in the
west he's interested in theological
questions as well as political questions
and i'm particularly interested in
talking to him because the conflict
between islam and the jewish and the
christian worlds is a theological and
political problem as well as a
psychological problem so
welcome i'm very much looking forward to
this conversation and i hope i have many
more of the same with many islamic
thinkers
so
thanks for agreeing to talk to me
thank you so much uh dr peterson it's a
pleasure and a privilege to have this
conversation with you and i hope this
should be the beginning of broader
conversations between muslims and
western intellectuals on the crucial
issues of peace coexistence freedom
toleration that we all need to have and
need to cultivate in our respective
traditions
so let me start with a really difficult
issue
that i've been thinking a lot about
lately partly because of the well some
of the
what would you say
incomprehensible goings on that bedevil
the western world at the moment now i've
been thinking a lot about this statement
in the new testament about rendering
unto god what is god's and unto caesar
what is caesar's the idea that there's a
clear distinction between those two and
i believe that to be true for
psychological reasons as well as
political reasons and it's an
extraordinarily notable statement in my
estimation
i don't know if you could find a single
sentence that anyone has ever said that
has had a bigger impact on the history
of the world because as i understand it
that statement was the justification for
the development in the west of political
processes that were independent of the
theological substructure beneath them
and the justification for that that
there were separate domains and that was
okay
theologically and so i want to know if
that's your understanding of the
situation as well and then we can talk
about
what that means for for islam where i i
understand that it's not so obvious
let's say that such a distinction can be
easily drawn
uh i would totally agree with you that
separation of church and state in the
western tradition has been a blessing
for humanity i mean west itself and the
broader i think human story and i think
that's evident in the fact that a lot of
muslims around the world today who are
persecuted in their countries come to
live in the west and where they find
freedom and if it was a christian
theocracy you know they wouldn't be
happily living there
i mean i a few times i said that i mean
there is one country in which all
denominations of islam happily live
together without any sectarian
persecution and
that is the united states of america and
i'm sure canada is doing pretty well or
uk pretty well
uh one thing i mean some of course
separate some models of separation of
religion and state sometimes went
ill-liberal towards religion
authoritarian towards religion and
that's a problem for example i see that
in the french
tradition and and when secularism is
understood in that sort of intolerant
way and somehow a bias towards religion
actually it becomes harder to accept
from a religious point of view and
one problem in the islamic tradition is
that we always had the french version in
my country turkey and in tunisia so we
never got a full sense of a
a liberal classically liberal
idea of secularism but i mean that's the
political story i mean we can discuss
more but coming back to your point
it is remarkable that actually a
statement from uh jesus christ you know
right there in the new testament has
been discovered and used to justify the
separation church and state i mean the
very life story of christ is
interesting i mean he was never the
state right he was he was actually
persecuted by the state
so there's a great story there but i
will also remind you one thing
for centuries christians didn't
understand the render on to caesar and
rendron to god as the justification of
secularism
actually it was used to justify divine
rights of kings as well i mean robert
filmer makes that argument in his
patriarcha and john locke argues against
him so it was used by christians to uh
to defend rewind divine rights of kings
but then other christians said hey no no
no there's a better understanding of
this it actually says there are separate
authorities here
and the one that the the divine
authority is what we're loyal to and the
political one should be based on
contracts so that gave us of course the
liberal tradition that i highly value
but i will say a similar process of
re-reading the scripture is taking place
in the muslim world in the past few
centuries past two centuries in the late
19th century a tradition broadly called
islamic modernism which i you know hope
to represent and i'm trying to advance
also said
well there are messages in the quran
that our classical scholars maybe didn't
fully get or didn't fully develop
because in their time and context it
wasn't possible but now we see the full
meaning of that for example one example
is
a powerful statement in the quran which
reads
in arabic which means there is no
compulsion in religion
i mean it doesn't say secure state but
it means religion should be based on no
compulsion in other words freedom
and this was there in the quran for
centuries and muslims made only a little
sense of this they said okay this means
you will not convert people to enter
islam generally that was observed in the
classical islamic tradition that's why
jews and christians could live under
islam
but they didn't understand it in other
ways for example this should mean that
perhaps if people want to convert out of
islam that is apostasy
it should be free too based on this
verse but no no they said you know
actually it doesn't mean that way so
they limited the meaning of the verse
and of course there was religious
policing checking people are really
pious or not for persecution of heretics
these things happen in islamic history
but now other muslim thinkers are saying
listen when god said there is no
compulsion in religion it's a universal
statement of
no compulsion in other words religious
freedom so that's a new reading that
muslim scholars of the more modernist or
reformist i think uh persuasion have
been advocating in the past let's say
two century and
my book was banned in malaysia precisely
because i irrigated religious freedom
based on such quranic basis well the the
the pathway from a statement like that
to a fully developed political and
theological system that are separate in
the details but somehow still able to
mutually function and in some sense one
still containing the other i would argue
you know even in the united states it's
one country under god that's in the
background all the time in some sense
and i would also say that
the elevation of the right to free
speech as perhaps the primary right and
i'm speaking psychologically here to
some degree
is a reflection in the political domain
i think of what was being developed
symbolically in christian theology with
the idea of the divine word
and and that that idea in many ways is
older than christianity it's it's older
than judaism as well like you can you
can you can see like i've traced that
back to it for example to the
mesopotamian writings about
marduk who was
that the the god who emerged at the
pinnacle of the mesopotamian gods and
who was the model for the sovereign of
the mesopotamian emperor and he had eyes
all the way around his head and he spoke
magic words
and so even if you trace our stories
back as far back as we've been able to
trace them the idea that there was
something divine about the word itself
so and we could have a discussion about
what that divinity means and i'm
interested in doing that because you
wrote this book um the islamic jesus how
the king of the jews became a prophet of
the muslims and that's that's
all of this
all of this is tangled up in some sense
in the figure of christ historically and
mythologically
and so
in the west i think we managed to
maintain the relationship between the
secular and the religious
by
putting forth these axiomatic rights
which are in some sense religious in
their derivation and they slaughtered
nicely into the religious understructure
but then simultaneously allowed for
enough freedom so the political could do
its own thing
and so
that's partly why i'm so curious about
your your writings about christ and
about his place in muslim thinking
obviously in the west whatever christ
was is
was elevated to the highest place right
now
how do you understand now i know christ
is a major figure in islamic thinking
but there are differences so can you
help me
can you wade me through that to some
degree
definitely uh first of all to enter a
discussion i should just maybe make one
broad statement and that is that in the
western world in the 20th century people
began to speak about the judeo-christian
tradition and i think it's a very
valuable way of looking into the world
yes there's a judeo-christian tradition
but i think there is something missing
in that
there's islam that is missing because i
think i see the world history and i look
at there is a judeo-crystal islamic
tradition because it's all abrahamic
monotheism coming from actually from
judaism and judaism had began i mean
historically initiated monotheism and
then it had a big outburst with
christianity the greatest outburst but
the greatest world
world's greatest religion but then
six centuries later it had a second
outburst with islam which spread
monotheism
in four corners of the world i mean
there are people in living indonesia
whose name is moses or abraham i mean
why are they coming i mean because islam
brought this biblical story that brings
us to
some instant discussion of what these
three abrahamic religions have in common
that's extraordinarily deep so one
they're monotheistic
two they partake of the same tradition
as you've pointed out and three
they all have
to one degree or another an insistence
that the bedrock of culture is a book
which is a very strange insistence that
it's it's taken for granted in some
sense because it's been insistent upon
so long but this is something that
like
it's very difficult to see in some ways
that a book lasts longer than a city or
an empire or a country and that there's
there's something profound about the
notion that the bedrock of a culture
should be a book and there is an
implicit respect for the word
in that insistence and that does unite
those three religions in a very profound
way
it does and i think
it can
it has created these amazing
civilizations which advance human
history and i think the very fact that
islam speaking of islam advanced human
history in terms of pluralism in terms
of law in terms of religious toleration
for its time
i think is undeniable and a lot of and
and the fact that islam even brought you
know greek philosophy because of its
universalism
muslims believe in the book but they
believe that reason is also from god so
they this created a universalistic
outlook
and muslims studied aristotle and plato
and even carried them to europe so there
is an amazing history there
which are the positive things but also
there are times that these religious
civilizations sometimes go
into a crisis
and they go self-destructive and bitter
and that has happened in europe i mean
and if you look into
17th century early 17th century europe
and catholics and protestants were you
know killing each other for sectarian
reasons i mean heretics were being
burned at the stake and which led people
like john locke to seek a way out and
they did it by looking into the core of
religion and saying that this is not
what christ had told us
i mean loxes i mean when i read his
letter concerning toleration i said well
he's speaking of christian issues but
he's speaking of our issues too the idea
that should there be a christian state
or not should heretics be persecuted or
not so he makes certain arguments or
would religion be based on sincerity if
it is coerced by the state it wouldn't
so there's no point in coercion so those
kind of arguments are i think very
interesting which i that's why
i i believe in reading these traditions
as by learning from each other instead
of thinking oh they are the christians
and they have nothing to do with us or
these are muslims they have nothing to
do with us well the problem the problem
with that perspective you know those are
the muslims and they have nothing to do
with us is that underneath such a
presumption is
let's say the presumption that
christians and muslims can't talk but
even deeper that than that is the
presumption on the part of the person
making such a statement that their
interpretation of christianity is
absolutely right
and that seems ridiculously presumptuous
to me no because
i i i don't think that you could find a
christian worth his salt let's say who
would regard himself as as stellar an
exemplar of christianity as christ and
you know since we all fall short of the
glory of god we're all stupid and
ignorant beyond belief and so we have to
listen to other people because they
might know something we don't
and then you see if we if we take that
other attitude then there's an implicit
totalitarianism
already there which is well i'm right
and you're not only wrong but wrong in
some way that's probably malevolent and
sometimes that's true but
it's not it's not a good way to start a
conversation
it is not and and i think religion
becomes most dangerous when it is
combined with group narcissism and
acting uh in the name of god to punish
people for their sins and heresies you
know as you define them and that has
happened in islam it still happens i
mean groups like isis al-qaeda those
terrorists i mean they are attacking
westerners but they are attacking fellow
muslims too and by defining them as
heretics i mean we see bombs of shiites
being
sorry mosques of shiites being bombed by
eight isis terrorists in the past
in the past two months it happened twice
and this is a destructive dynamic which
has been always extreme in islam but
existed and but there are antidotes to
this sort of thinking as well and and i
i sometimes read those antidotes and i
say oh in the christian tradition here's
an example of that i mean if you can uh
for example let me give you an example
one the big dispute in early islam was
who was the true muslim like there was a
civil war between the first muslims it's
called the first fitness
and supporters of ali and moabi had the
two figures and i would sympathize with
ali but they had a war and and there's a
fanatic
faction called the hawari the dissenters
and they said these are both they have
gone wrong they have sinned because they
have sinned they are not muslims they
become infidels
and infidels should be punished so they
started killing them they were like the
terrorists of the first century always
hated by mainstream muslims
but what they were doing is to judge
people and punish them in the name of
god but there was a alternative theology
called murja theology and it's it's
called murjah in arabic means postponer
they said
on this issue of who's right and wrong
we don't know
we cannot judge only god can judge so
let's postpone this to afterlife to be
resolved by god and until then until it
is resolved by god in heaven when we go
there we can live and let live so they
promoted toleration among muslims
now this actually allowed calming down
some of the early violence and
broad coexistence in different uh
factions of islam and i think still it
was brought into sunni islam by abu
hanifah and the hanafi school and added
broader acceptance
and i was particularly struck to read
something very similar
in john locke in his letter concerning
toleration he says there are different
churches for every church the third is
theirs they are orthodox to themselves
and if one of them dominate government
they will persecute others and he says
let's leave this to almighty the judge
to decide which doctrine is right
and in the meantime let the government
only protect the rights the natural
rights of all people and let people
follow that's part of the thorny
psychological problem of rendering unto
caesar what is caesar's and unto god
what is god's because a lot of times now
when people talk about tolerance
they insist that judgment is wrong
and in in essence in
some sense and the reason they're afraid
of judgment is because in its extremes
it can lead to the demonization of
others and we know exactly where that
goes but there's no dispensing with
judgment you can't even look at
something without judgment because you
have to pick what you're going to look
at instead of something else and you
can't act without judgment and so
all of us are faced with this problem of
of
well what what we should believe and and
how we can be tolerant at the same time
we believe and how we can be tolerant at
the same time that we have to judge and
and there's a kernel in that in that
insistence by by by lock it was locked
you were referring to or was it mills
they let they let her on tolerance
i was just referring to john locke sorry
it's lock yeah okay and you just slip my
mind for a second
it's very difficult for us to figure out
what we can tolerate if we must
simultaneously believe right
and that's a problem i've been trying to
work out psychologically for a very long
time it's
you do that you see that in your own
family when you're a father let's say
because
you obviously have to have tolerance for
your children but at the same time
you're obligated to
show them the difference let's say
between right and wrong and also to help
them separate the wheat from the chaff
which is judgment
and so
well i i totally see her see the point
the balance you're pointing out here but
i agree with that's why i use the term
tolerance because i mean
you might not need to accept everything
and cherish and bless everything but you
need to accept different ways of life or
theologies or doctrines
and by judgment i mean of course we can
have value judgments i judge a lot of
people in society i say these people are
bigoted or these people are arrogant and
or their way of life is destructive for
themselves
i have those judgments but i'm not going
to go and punish them in the name of god
unless they attack me so there should be
a social order in which we can
disapprove people uh ways of life
religious beliefs theologies and and our
religions make truth statements and we
cannot get away from that i mean you say
christ is god the other person will say
well no that's not acceptable for my
theology so there are gaps that we
cannot
uh and we should not you know try to
make make disappear but we can live
together and that's why tolerance is the
key idea and that's why by judgment what
i'm referring to is judging and
punishing
in the name of god and of course crime
will be punished i mean theftfully
punished or murderfully punished but if
someone has a doctrine religious
doctrine that i find wrong i should
tolerate that person although i can you
know criticize of course and and we can
and that and i can be criticized back
which what free speech allows of course
for us so i mean sorry you asked me
about christ but i i uh
i mean i opened a broader chapter if you
will you want to you want me to go into
that discussion yes yes that would be
good
uh i mean for a lot of christians who
may not much know much about the muslim
world i mean it might be surprising to
learn that
the most prominent
female figure in the whole quran is mary
actually she's the only woman mentioned
by name there's a chapter named mary
there's a chapter named after her family
ali imran and the quran because
because the the calling of the quran is
to say
this is a new this is not a new religion
this is monotheism muhammad is god's
messenger but god had other messengers
before there was moses there was abraham
there was jesus christ and there was his
mary and the quran tells the story of
mary to
affirm something which is
again might be surprising to christians
the quran affirms the virgin birth of
christ
that
mary was a chaste woman she didn't she
was not touched by any man and one day
she heard an angel coming and say you
will have a son and she says how can i
have a son no man has ever touched me
but but the angel says this is what god
willed and he wills and he creates so
that is how christ christ you know uh
comes
to you know his mother's uh womb and
ultimately he comes and the quran calls
him the word of god again this is a very
powerful statement if you if you're if
one is familiar with the
gospel of john and this is very unusual
but the same quran also insists that he
was not divine so he should not be
worshipped so on the one hand it
reversed mary and jesus
it tells a lot of things very similar to
gospel of luke and some apocryphal
gospels also resonate strongly with the
quran interestingly
so there's great respect great reverence
there are good words about christians i
mean one in words one verse
the quran says among all people you will
love the christians nearest to the
believers that that's the muslims
because it says they're not arrogant and
they have learned
they have learned scholars and
so there are a lot of positive things
because islam was born let's not forget
that islam was born as a monotheist
campaign
in an idolatrous society
meccans were worshiping idols and
prophet muhammad who didn't think of
becoming a prophet until the age of 40.
he heard the voice in a cave
angel gabriel like a burning bush
experience of moses which told him
recite in the name of god who created
man and then
he became convinced that he's god's
prophet and he started to preach
monotheism and when you preach
monotheism
muslims consider jews and christians as
their allies that's why when muslims
were muslims were persecuted in
mecca prophet muhammad told a group of
muslims to flee to ethiopia the
christian kingdom of ethiopia they went
there and they were really saved by the
christian king that's a memory that
muslims have so there is that
monotheistic so what what does it mean
in islam that christ well two things
that you said that that christ is
his birth is the virgin birth is
accepted that's that's a major issue
which we should also discuss and also
the emphasis on mary and what that means
let's say for the position of women
theologically within islam and and also
what does it mean when
muslims claim believe that christ is the
word of god
now it's hard for me as a westerner to
separate that out from claims of
divinity and and and we could also talk
in some sense about worship about what
worship means and so when i i try to
look at these things from a
psychological perspective as much as
possible and stay out of theological
territory where i'm a neophyte in any
case
um
one of the things that worship means to
me psychologically is something like
the desire or compulsion to imitate
like you think about to worship
something is to place it in the place of
highest value
and you know
people
claim to think that actions speak louder
than words and i think that's a
reasonable proposition if you act
something out it's pretty compelling
evidence that you believe it and
that means in some ways that you hold it
in the highest place and so to worship
is to imitate i think in the deepest
sense
it might be to celebrate what should be
imitated as well something like that and
this is a complicated issue because
we're unbelievably imitative
and i was struck when my kids were
little when they were playing house for
example my son would play out the father
and you might say well he was copying
his dad but he wasn't because he wasn't
moving the same way he saw me move what
he was doing was
watching me over a whole variety of
instances
and then also watching
portrayals of fathers in media movies
and tv shows and that sort of thing and
abstracting out from that some kind of
i would call it
like a disembodied spirit which
represented the core essence of
paternity and then imitating that
and and i see in that
the biological underpinnings let's say
of what religious people talk about when
they talk about worship so when the
muslim world regards christ as the word
of god
but but not divine i i don't know how to
i don't know how to understand that
uh very good question i mean
it says in the quran that he is a word
from god
and it doesn't explain much and muslims
discuss what this means exactly uh it's
not certainly understood in the way that
the gospel of john defines that word was
word was with god and word was god so
that's not the beginning of time yeah no
that's not the step taken there most
common interpretations said well he was
the word of god in the sense that god
it was the word of god directed to mary
so god he was created with the creator
word be in mary's body so that's what it
means so that's generally a like a low
interpret low christology if you will
but there are alternative views which i
mentioned you know in my book uh in the
islamic jesus that some people said
maybe he was worth the word of god in
the sense that
he was the revelation itself like
everything he did and said was
revelation like god's living word
which still though from an isla which
which means he was something like the
quran like quran we believe is
revelation god's revelation so he was he
was the revelation became flesh rather
than revelation became a book right and
that's why the new testament
narrates about jesus i mean it's it he
is the he is the revelation and new
testaments are reports about the
revelation so that's i think that's
possible to uh
that's a step possible to take within
the quranic framework however still
muslims don't worship the quran i mean
you say still god is beyond i mean god
is another transcendent at another
transcendent level and in islam
so let's let's talk about that in
relationship to the totalitarian impulse
okay i mean i was i just had a
discussion with sam harris and i
mentioned that i was going to be talking
to some islamic scholars i didn't
mention you by name and i asked him if
he might want to participate in such a
discussion he said he's done that he's
done there and he's been there and done
that and so he wasn't particularly
interested in that
although we had a wonderful conversation
but one of the
what what i see happening very
frequently with thinkers like harrison
and i'm saying this with all due respect
i truly am is that for them
there is very little distinction between
the religious and the totalitarian and
that's the essence of the objection now
sam has come to regard some domains as
sacred and we talked a lot about that
and i think that it's i think it's an
understatement of the severity of the
totalitarian problem to attribute it
merely to the religious
and the part of the reason i think that
is well look what happened in the 20th
century in the west it's like well there
was
the nazis and how about mao and then
there's stalin and you know you could
say those were religions but you know
you're pretty
you're weasley were you're using weasel
words at that point you expand the
definition of what constitutes religion
so it doesn't violate your initial
presuppositions
and so
we could see in christianity and in
judaism and in islam the constant human
struggle
to deal with whatever is the
totalitarian impulse which is something
like insistence that what i already know
is well is literally the word of god
it's in some sense it's absolutely true
i have the knowledge there shall be no
deviation from that
and and to to
us to
identify that with
tradition in religion i think is a big
mistake it's it it doesn't get to the
issue
i'm totally on the same page with you on
that i mean uh the history of 20th
century shows that some of the greatest
crimes against humanity were considered
were committed by secular ideologies i
mean communism and nazism as you well
put
and today probably the worst
totalitarian regimes in the world number
one is north korea i mean it's it's not
a really it's a secular state but it's a
bit a juche called ideology but it's
totally secular so
being i mean i'm in favor of a secular
state in terms of a neutral state that
respects everybody's rights regardless
of religion or creed but secularization
of society
it doesn't necessarily bring anything
good i mean we have seen that okay so
let's talk about that for a second so
i've been trying to figure out
all right so one of the things i
realized a long time ago as a
psychologist was that there were depths
of meaning
and we have intimations of this
constantly so for example
we can read a book and we think that was
shallow and we can read another book and
we think that was deep and then when we
talk to a bunch of other people they
tend to think that the shallow book was
shallow and the deep book was deep and
they tend to think that shallow and deep
actually mean something
and so there's this there's this
experience of depth
now
i've tried to figure out what that meant
exactly and what occurred to me was that
and this was partly
derived from watching people in my
clinical practice
so imagine people will get much more
upset
about a pending divorce than they will
about a discussion about who should do
the dishes and you think well that's
obvious it's like yeah
it's it's obvious because that's what
happens to you but it isn't easy to
explain
so what i thought was what i
hypothesized was something like
we have representations of the world of
different sizes and different temporal
expanses a small plan for the day nested
inside a plan for the week and nested
inside a plan for the month the year
nested inside our family nested inside
our community nested inside our polity
nested inside our theology
okay and the deeper you go
the more those representations are
dependent on
the more representations are dependent
on that level
and so when something happens to you
where you're deeply affected or
traumatized let's say technically what's
happened is that you've taken a blow to
a representation upon which almost all
your other representations depend
and so then you could think technically
about the difference between the secular
and the religious as being one of depth
once you go down to the
fundamental substrata so that would be
the most axiomatic of presuppositions
whether you're secular or not you're in
the religious domain
yeah
okay okay okay so i mean the people who
call themselves secular and of course i
have many friends who are secular and i
respect that point of view but they have
metaphysical beliefs at the end of the
day i mean if you say the universe
always existed and matter it made us and
you know that's your creation story i
mean every every worldview has
ultimately a metaphysical uh dimension i
think even if if it does accept like
coming back to your totalitarianism
point
we have totalitarian
entities right now i mean in the world
in the name of islam i mean i think the
iranian republic is pretty much the
islamic republic of iran pretty close to
that saudi arabia
is i mean very oppressive and these are
the two most oppressive interpretations
of islam isis is like khmer rouge i mean
he was the khmer rouge of the islamic
spectrum so it was pretty
evil and very i think totalitarian too
but there was something though in
classical islam although i have a lot of
criticisms towards medieval
jurisprudence but there was a value in
classical islam
and that that value was in in this word
which is a generally scary word in the
western today and that's the sharia you
know that's god's law
i mean i there are two phases of the
sharia there are a lot of things about
women and apostasy and blasphemy that i
keep criticizing that we have to reform
those aspects but there was another
value in the sharia which highlighted my
book new book why as a muslim i defend
liberty the sharia was a set of laws
that were separate from the rulers they
were even even above the rulers like
sharia wasn't what the sultan
required or you know wanted the sharia
was the law of god articulated by
scholars who were generally independent
of the rulers
that's why the classical medieval
islamic civilization wasn't totalitarian
there were a lot of autocratic rulers
tyrants but they were mitigated by the
sharia and and i i tell them so this is
also something that i think people like
harris let's say
and and those atheist rationalists i
think they failed to understand the
necessity of that so
i mentioned ancient mesopotamia a while
back but one thing that happened in that
society was that
the emperor would be taken outside the
gates of the city so it was a walled
city
once a year at the new year's festival
and he would be stripped of his empire
emperor garb and forced to kneel and
then the priest would slap him with a
glove and he would be forced to recite
all the ways that he hadn't been an
appropriate marduk which was the high
god for the last year so he hadn't seen
what he should see if he wasn't being
blind and he hadn't said what he should
have said if he was speaking the right
kind of magic and so he was he was
humbled in front of what was highest and
the mesopotamians were working hard you
know in their mythology you see this
battle between the gods in the face of
an apocalyptic danger and this is a very
common story worldwide this battle
between the gods so what's highest
in the face of an apocalyptic danger and
the emergence of a supreme principle
which constitutes the essence of
sovereignty itself and if you have a
society a secular society let's say
where that highest thing isn't outside
the polity in some sense then you have
north korea where the leader is elevated
to the status of a god and then you have
hell
and that seems like a bad idea exactly
you have stalin you have mao you have uh
all those modern dictators and you have
the islamist you know
totalitarian regimes today because the
islamist totalitarians of today differ
from the classical medieval islamic
tradition i mean imagine
i mean look at taliban today i mean
taliban has dominated afghanistan once
again
the head of the taliban is also the head
of the executive and the judiciary
and the ex i mean legislation so that
wasn't like that in classical islam
there was a ruler
but there were also scholars who were
independent from the they were
independent in the beginning and
rulers gradually actually co-opted
scholars and that was the beginning of
the doom of the decline of the islamic
civilization my friend ahmed kuru has a
very good book about that he shows how
the scholar religious scholars who
develop law were gradually co-opted by
the state by the rulers and that
actually killed the diversity and
dynamism of islamic thought it means
that they've lo they've been lowered
from the from the ultimate to the to the
political particular and that's a
catastrophe exactly and uh i mean there
are many tales in islamic civilization
today i think we can highlight to uh
articulate values like rule of law or
separation of powers i mean i tell one
of them for example we know that in
ottoman history ottoman sultans were
stopped by rulers sometimes from
executing people out of just anger or
confiscating property or over taxing the
population they said this tax is not
compatible with the sharia you can over
tax people so they so there was a
balance in the classical islamic
civilization which work for its time and
let's not forget that classical islamic
civilization had a toleration which
again was not very common at the time
that's why when jews were persecuted in
europe
they often fled to the islamic lands i
mean the ottoman empire unfortunately
today we have a crisis in the islamic
civilization we lost some of the
blessings of the classical tradition
that tradition itself stagnated its
jurisprudence stagnated and then we had
the modern state and these islamic
movements came with the passion to grab
the modern state and use it in the name
of islam which created a deadly mix of
medieval jurisprudence and modern
totalitarianism which is the story of
the iranian islamic republic of iran
saudi arabia is going towards the
direction of andre let's talk about the
saudis for a sec if you don't mind i
mean yeah sure okay because why why not
do something incredibly dangerous i mean
i i
am stunned at the naivety of the west
in
rendering unto the wahhabis a fortune of
staggering magnitude
and thinking that in some way this was a
recipe for medium and long-term peace
i mean i don't how why do you think
we're so stupid
just out of curiosity i mean i think
every government in the world is stupid
in the sense that you know they make
decisions on very short-term interest
without really understanding the
long-term consequences the stupidity of
western governments just have more
impact because they have more power you
know to shape things
uh regarding to wahhabis i mean
for for example i mean first of all
let's establish what wahhabism is
wahhabism is i mean
first of all islam should be compared
more to judaism than christianity to
make i think meaningful analogies
because of its theology is very similar
to judaism and the idea of law sharia
and
are very similar traditions so in islam
sunni islam is like orthodox judaism
it's the mainstream body right it's
traditional conservative but it has some
flexibility
and then there's the ultra orthodox you
know tradition
in judaism so wahhabism represents the
ultra ultra-orthodox
point of view with a violent and
intolerant
bent to it so that emerged in the 18th
century in the ottoman empire and their
first targets were other muslims i mean
they can they condemn the ottoman empire
for being into a heresy and bida as they
call it innovation
they attack sunnis
fellow sunnis and also slaughtered
shiites which they consider as heretics
then when the ottoman empire banned
slave trade in the middle of the 19th
century there was a revolt in hijaz
fueled by wahhabis they said turks have
gone infidels because slavery is in our
jurisprudence you cannot change that
though although the ottomans were more
flexible in their understanding but
until the 20th century wahhabism was
a very regressive
like a force in the middle of the
arabian desert nations which people
didn't know they didn't go there it was
a very marginal force
in the 20th century these people
discovered that they are sitting on the
world on top of the world's richest oil
reserves which they consider as a
blessing from god to use you know to
advance their
understanding and also western powers
thought that oh we can use them i mean
we can get a deal with them first the
british first the british thought that
they could be used against the ottoman
empire
uh there was even some discussion that
there are like protestantism which are
potentially more tolerant which is not i
mean they're not like protestants but
they were certainly not tolerant so that
was one thing first of all because the
ottoman empire being the seat of the
caliphate and the superpower
that was the problem although you would
prefer the ottomans to the wahhabis by
any definition because of their
toleration and pluralism for their time
and then of course so so you're you're
making the case to some degree if i
understand you right that
a polit
a totalitarian doctrine let's say
was granted exceptional riches which
there's no possibility they could have
accrued had that theology that
totalitarian theology had to make its
way in its own way in the world
but because of the vagaries of fate in
some sense
there was immense riches
at the fingertips of this movement that
would have otherwise been and likely
remained extraordinarily isolated
yes what i'm saying is that i mean uh
there are i'm not saying that the
classical islamic world was full i mean
it was not ideal there was a lot of
persecution of heretics and here and
there too but for its time
you wouldn't judge the classical islamic
civilization and say they have less
religious freedom compared to what was
there at christendom at the time that's
where that's why jews repeatedly fled to
the muslim world for example from spain
to the ottoman empire
in the modern era
one problem is islamic jurisprudence the
interpretation of the sharia stagnated
and why that happened is a big
discussion among muslims but that's one
problem
and and the idea of a modern state came
the modern state with its police and
which is national law controlling
everything with its bureaucracy
and it come and islamist movements
emerge saying that we will revive the
sharia by grabbing the modern state by
all its centralized power and that
created the
totalitarian movement in islamic
tradition and and we see that in saudi
arabia we see that in iran we're seeing
that in under the taliban
so there's and one problem is that
islamic world in the past two centuries
modernized
but we didn't get the good forms of
modernity
uh one thing
i mean first of all the only secularism
muslims experienced was was the
french-style securism which generally
pushed back the believers because if you
say i'm bringing you saccharism it's a
wonderful thing which means you will not
be able to wear a head scarf and go to
the campus well there's not much freedom
in that securism so unfortunately
it gave bad name to that secondly
arab republics
got influenced by soviet communism i
mean arab socialism was a very powerful
move
in the middle of the 20th century
republican turkey my country
uh it is it westernized it's good but
you know it acquired its legal system
from fascist italy
uh in the 1930s because let's not forget
i mean the west was not always a liberal
democratic heaven there were a lot of
bad ideas that came from the west so i
see this today in the islamic
civilization a really a perfect storm a
crisis of
some we lost some of the traditions we
have some of the toleration and
pluralism we had back then
there's a stagnant jurisprudence and bad
ideas of modernity came and when you mix
them there's a crisis in every society
and and and that's why i think we
muslims need ideas that will be new
different than what we have before but
that should be rooted in the tradition
bad ideas from the west are in fact
devastating i mean when cultures object
to western hegemony in favor of their
local traditions let's say i have a
certain amount of uh what would you say
understanding of why they're doing that
because
the ideas that emerged
after the renaissance let's say
especially ideas that
undermined religious tradition are
unbelievably difficult to withstand
and that's still causing all sorts of
trouble in the west and it's caused all
sorts of political trouble in the west
not least this development of this
absolutely anti-liberal
totalitarianism that you saw in both
nazism and communism and in the west you
know we like to look at free modernity
and say well that's
that's us in the last 500 years but
those offshoots
the soviet union and nazi germany are
just as much a part of that tradition as
well as
as the more positive elements of
modernity and so and that's where that's
why i think that this conflation of the
totalitarian impulse with the religious
impulse
is dangerous now i understand though
there's another issue here that's
lurking beneath the surface constantly
is that
there's the spiritual element in some
sense of of religious
the perception and practice and there's
the tradition
and you know you see those juxtaposed to
some degree in the new testament when
the pharisees and the and the lawyers
attempt to
trap christ into saying something
heretical when they ask him to rank
order the mosaic commandments what's the
most important commandment which implies
that some of them aren't so important
and he just sidesteps that so absolutely
brilliantly and says well if i remember
correctly that you should love god above
all else and love your brother like
yourself and
and what he did there was extract out
the essence of the root tradition and
make that into something that's an
embodied dynamic conscious practice and
that's
it's one of those stories you read and
you think
what the hell was going on there how
could someone come up with an answer
like that that's such a devastating
remarkable creative answer and of course
it's had a huge impact on the
civilization of the world since then but
you know the people who criticize
religion the materialist atheist types
for example they constantly conflate the
problem of the totalitarian proclivity
that tradition
tends towards if unchecked with religion
itself and that's a huge problem because
those aren't the same thing
they're not and i think
religion obviously has become oppressive
in world history when it's when it
combines with state power it becomes the
same thing with state power and that's
what theocracy and we have examples of
that in christian history and obviously
in islamic history but religion can also
be a balance to power it can hold values
outside of the power sphere and actually
check power so and i think there are
grounds for that in the christian
tradition and and of course in the
islamic tradition and we have to
cultivate those but i think this whole
discussion of religion and power
requires a rethinking of the very birth
story of islam how prophet muhammad came
and
what he preached so and i have some
ideas some some reformist perspectives
there i mean i can speak about that a
little bit please do please do uh
here's here's one thing that here's one
thing that clouds
uh thinkings thinking about islam by
sometimes muslims and by sometimes
others and that is that in the very
beginning of islam you see prophet
a preacher a preacher of monotheism a
prophet but also somebody who
led armies who led battles who establish
a state so what is going on right that's
why i mean some people say you know in
christianity it's much easier to make
the case for a secular state but in
islam it's much more difficult because
they have the state at the very
beginning and it also makes muhammad
into quite a frightening figure i mean
on the one hand when i look at what he
did
the fact that
it it
it fits in this pattern that has
happened time and time again in
religious history where
the warring i'd idolatry was united into
a monotheism and that's a civilizing
force it means that it means integration
and of course
the the empire that resulted was one of
the largest empires that humans have
ever created it was an unbelievable
achievement so there's this push towards
monotheism and insistence on a highest
like transcendent value but as you just
pointed out at the same time well yeah
but there was war and there was conquest
and that's absent from the story of
christ completely and so it's it's quite
frightening from a western perspective
i understand that but that's why i think
we need a discussion about that which i
you know offer in in my books especially
reopening muslim minds and i calling i
call for understanding why prophet
muhammad had to fight wars was that a
divine blueprint that he had to fulfill
or was that a
accident of history that he was forced
into i mean and before that i'll just
say one thing
uh there are i mean we have to compare
islamic christianity but to understand
islam also always check
the old testament because i think that
his story of prophet muhammad is also
very similar to the story of moses and
also the later joshua and the you know
wars in the land of canon and so there
are a lot of old testament parallels
there so here is what happened at the
very birth of islam prophet muhammad
began preaching monotheism in the city
of mecca in year 2010 actually he didn't
preach publicly in the beginning for
three years they were secret
they were just about 40 people
gradually it became a community and they
publicly began
preaching there's one god and no god
right
and of course the god of abraham it was
very clear that it's a continuation of
the abrahamic tradition
now
for ten years because of this they were
persecuted
the the pagan
big grandes of the city the
the leaders of the tribes they said to
muhammad you're insulting our religion
you're defying our gods you're insulting
our forefathers in other words they
accuse prophet muhammad for blasphemy
against their religion and which i think
should be in the minds of every muslim
today on free speech issues
and but muslims didn't give up but
muslims didn't threaten there was no act
of violence muslims were not trying to
found an army and actually there are
passages in the quran which shows that
muslims were just preaching their fate
and one of them reads to you your
religion and to me mine i mean that was
a statement made to the pagans another
one says the lord the truth is from your
lord let anyone who want to believe it
believe it let anyone who want to
disbelieve it disbelieve it
another verse says to muhammad oh
muhammad you're just a preacher you're
not a compeller over people and if god
had willed everybody would believe but
you know god led it this way so there's
a very
non
there's a non-political and non-violent
message right there in mecca
now i ask a question that generally
people didn't ask what if the meccan
said okay do what you do right and what
if the meccans said let the muslims go
and preach their religion
i think the history of islam would be
different because muslims were just
going to peacefully preach the faith
probably faith would grow and it would
gradually win over the city and still
the kaaba would be transformed into a
monotheistic temple but it would be a
different history what rather happened
is that they they persecuted the muslims
they killed muslims
some of them had to flee to ethiopia as
i said they were almost coming to clo
kill prophet muhammed himself
assassinate him and that's why he
finally fled
mecca and went to the city yatrip called
medina later
and there he established a community he
established a group of people he became
a political leader in the city
and all their properties were plundered
after they were left their homes were
raided and they were sold
they were raided by the pagans
and then came the first verse of the
quran which allowed war jihad a military
jihad in the name of god and that was in
surah hajj is very interesting it says
permission to fight has been given to
those who have been persecuted
they were persecuted because they said
our lord is one they were driven out of
their homes because they said our lord
is one so the war aspect the war part of
the story was the reaction to
persecution the ongoing persecution
once you start war it went on there were
many battles like in the ten last years
the 10 years in mecca there are raids
there are battles there are fights and
when you read the quran today in certain
chapters surah 9 for example
you will see harsh passages go and fight
the unbelievers go and find them go and
kill them you know
and those are historical commandments
directing the first muslim community
just like commandments in the old
testament
telling joshua or the israelites you
know to fight the
the amalekites you know the tribes in
the land of canaan that were trying to
kill the israelites
so i understand the war aspect there as
an outcome of a
oppressive environment which wouldn't
let islam to grow and even exist so
muslims had to fight not because they
wanted
but they were forced into however a
problem
the whole thorny moral problem of what
you should do when you're oppressed is
not something that we've as a species
let's say have completely figured out i
mean in christianity i would
say you
propose that one of the prime
injunctions is to turn the other cheek
but
that that didn't seem to apply so
obviously let's say in in the decades
leading to world war ii
and and so yeah
it's not like every society doesn't have
to wrestle with this problem i mean
christ is presented as a pacemaker
there's no doubt about that but he's
also presented in the book of revelation
as a judge who separates the damn from
the elect and there's a harshness in
that as well
and so
i don't think it's
go ahead sorry but there is an
additional problem i mean i mean the
founding story is not a problem but i
think we have to understand it correctly
that war was a
consequence of that particular context
and what is eternal about islam to me is
the theology that the faith the practice
and the worship that was brought by
islam but there was an additional
problem
after prophet muhammad passed away uh
muslims had an army and a state and they
kept continuing i mean they kept uh
conquering the world and from in one
century from spain to
india basically muslims built an empire
and this empire itself
partly transformed islamic teaching and
adjusted it to its imperial needs
and i think that's something we muslims
should see today one clear example of
this is the theory of abrogation
uh
because
the the jurists who were with the
imperial project they looked at the
quran and and they saw that well there
are verses in the quran which says
uh you're not a you're just a preacher
not a compeller well but we're having a
war here right like i mean to you your
religion to be mine but we are not
allowing the polytheists to to have this
so what they did was they took the
verses about war and fighting the
unbelievers the polytheists in
particular but also jews and christians
because there was a word about
the people of the book
they took those verses as definitive
which abrogated the earlier verses
so a lot of the verses you will open and
read the quran today which are tolerant
peaceful you know lenient
uh
if you read medieval jurisprudence you
will find notes that the verse is there
in the quran but it's abrogated like it
doesn't have a function it doesn't rule
it doesn't have a hukum
which to me is a huge problem when
you're dealing with a text as
complicated as the quran or let's say
the bible where
taken singly there are certainly
passages that contradict one another and
so then well then you were tempted by
the
desire to
justify your own unquestioned beliefs
because of your demand for power using
reference to god and then it's a worse
problem than that too because well who's
right in their interpretation you know
and the way out of that in some sense is
to approach
a book like that
with as much admission of your own
ignorance and as much humility as
possible so that
i mean if you assume that such thing is
reasonable given that we're all people
of the book and pray to god in some
sense that you don't bend that to your
own
unacknowledged malevolence and ignorance
but that's a very very difficult thing
to manage and it isn't even clear when
you manage it which is why we need to
talk to each other in part
exactly and i see this abrogation theory
and and the theory of jihad and conquest
and and coercion built around that which
is right honestly right there in the
islamic jurisprudence in medieval
interpretations of the sharia as islam
interpreted for the age of empires i
mean it was how empires were behaving at
the time christians were doing the same
things too i mean byzantine empire was
also expanding through
war
they had anti-paganism laws
religious coercion was the norm of the
day islam was born in such a world and
it took a imperial form and
jurisprudence but to me it was not a
divine blueprint that we muslims should
preserve forever it was a different
context and we live in a different world
today so that's why we have to
reinterpret and to me the abrogated
verses of the quran are the eternal
messages of islam
those abrogated verses which says to you
your religion to be mine and
okay so
why would you why okay so let me play
devil's advocate here i mean you're
making you're making a judgment there
and it's a non-trivial judgment and you
could say also that it's an unbelievably
presumptuous judgment and this is not an
insult at all this is independent of
whether or not i agree with you but we
run right into this thorny problem right
which is well why
on what grounds do you think you're
justified in making the claim that your
interpretation should supersede that
particular interpretation
very good question
first of all i begin with showing that i
begin by showing that
the existing interpretation the imperial
interpretation let's say which relied on
expensive jihad coercion suppression of
heresy apostasy laws blasphemy laws
that's all part of that
by showing that this was not a
inevitable interpretation it was an
interpretation based on imperial
conditions and i showed that people who
dissented against those two i mean in my
book in reopening muslim minds i said
well this became the mainstream view but
wait wait there was a scholar who was
actually you know arguing against that
there was a scholar who was saying no we
don't need abrogation we just need to
understand it
as one big story with different emphases
there were so there were
and i show how
these were cynically used by muslim
rulers sometimes to just get rid of
dissent i mean some muslims early
critics of the umayya dynasty which was
mostly a tyrannical dynasty that
dominated the islamic world they were
killed as blasphemers or apostates but
they were only critics of the rulers so
this is so let me ask you okay so let me
ask you another question so you've
you've spent a lot of time on this
you've written many books and you've put
yourself in some danger i would say and
and this has been quite successful and
so
i want to know what you're up to
you know what i mean it's like
you're you're aiming at something with
all these books and maybe you don't even
fully know what it is because you
realize these things as you write right
and as you struggle and so i would say
for a book like the bible like there's a
way that you have to approach it
i believe that what would you say so
that
you're the least likely to deceive
yourself about what you're doing
and that has to be something like i
think it has to be something like an
orientation towards love
and love is something like the desire
that the the most possible good happens
to the most possible people i don't mean
to be utilitarian about it i'm not
making that kind of case but it even
extends to your enemies because well
wouldn't it be better if they didn't
have such miserable lives and wouldn't
be better if you didn't have enemies and
so
you have to approach it a traditional
text in the spirit that the text
fundamentally embodies or you bend it to
your own will now you what are you
aiming at with all your books what what
is it that you want
that's a good question well what do i
want i want to make
as a just a
ordinary but thinking muslim i want to
make a contribution to to the future of
my religion
in this day and age where i see great
value in islam i think islam can
contribute to the world in many ways
but i also see islam being still
captured by some medieval
interpretations that were actually using
was was used and built up for medieval
imperial projects
and and i need i believe we need to
rethink certain issues in islam and
there are a lot of scholars doing this i
mean that's why i speak of the 19th
century islamic modernists i mean i
learned from these scholars from fazu
rahman to
muhammad abdul to admin liberals and
today some contemporary scholars that i
quote in my book as well but scholars
write in academic articles so i i or
very complicated books i try to
popularize these ideas because i see
there's hunger for that i mean there are
a lot of muslims around the world today
from pakistan to malaysia to indonesia
to the arab world
who are faithful who are happy with
their religion but they are disturbed
sometimes disgusted by the things they
see in the name of their religion
oppression violence persecution of
innocent people by calling them heretics
and so on so forth and they want to see
a way forward how can we go forward by
preserving our faith living our values
but also being at peace with non-muslims
and even muslims of different persuasion
and we can have so do you see that that
what is perturbing them is the
manifestation of that central
totalitarian spirit
it is totalitarian or just sometimes
bigger than hateful it i mean to be
totalitarian it has to be unified with
power but it is potentially totalitarian
so yeah well there's the psychological
equivalence psychology exactly and and i
also see that this is uh make this is
also leading to a great this enchantment
for islam as well i mean a lot of people
are not in the west thinking about that
they think muslim world everybody is
pious but quite the contrary there is a
great escape from islam in iran i mean
iran today is the number one country in
the world that produces ex-muslims like
people who become atheists and
christians and i respect their point of
view i mean they have all the right to
become 80s or christians but as a muslim
who believes in my faith i mean
like i would like to have a faith that
attracts people with its spirituality
and with its values but not frightens
them and scares them and pushes them
away in turkey my country there is a new
type of deism which is like young people
are believing in god but not any
religion and certainly not islam
precisely because of the disenchantment
of islam being used for authoritarian
politics by the current government for
example so i think this is a critical
period in islam and when i look back in
christian history i see people
uh
christian humanists from loch to others
roger williams in the united states who
re-articulated their religion
reinterpreted their religion to
emphasize freedom freedom of conscience
uh like i mean the switch from divine
rights of kings to the idea of a you
know limited government with uh which
with religious freedom that was a big
shift in christianity and it had to be
done by christians who value their fate
and i i think this is a big effort a lot
of muslims are trying i'm just trying to
do my part with my writings which are
aimed at a broad understanding with a
broad population so everybody can read
and get it you know what what the point
is but also here are the key
arguments and and the you know patterns
for going forward
yeah well you're you're a strange sort
of traditionalist in some sense right
because you are trying to separate the
wheat from the chaff in relationship to
the past but also not proposing that all
of this be abandoned as an entirely
failed project which i think is a very
naive would be a very naive thing to do
in any case it's like well
abandon it in favor of what exactly well
you know rationality it's well okay but
it's a need some fleshing out
well not by rationality i mean we can't
discuss that because you know my book
reopening muslim minds a return to
reason you know begins with that
reasonable freedom uh i'm not a
rationalist in the sense of you know
people like sam harris that you know you
talk to so i don't think that there's
reason that supersedes everything else
and by rationally we can always arrive
at throat i mean mao rationally arrived
at a terrible through so i i certainly
see well there's a lot of problem of the
axiomatic pressure i mean hayek you know
criticizes you know rationalists that
build systems of authoritarianism and i
think there was a great value there
however
by reason i refer to a specific
theological branch in islam called
rational theology or akul that's the
term in arabic reason and it goes back
to a
theological dispute in early islam
between two schools of thought
and it was on the meaning of sharia i
mean god's god's commandments
and actually it goes back to this was a
discussion on islam and but it goes back
to socrates and his famous europhro
dilemma and i think this was discussed
in christianity as well
the dilemma is this when god has
commandments like ten commandments like
thou shall not murder right thou shall
not steal these are fundamental key
values that mu our civilizations go
forward
but one question is this
does god say thou shall not murder
because murder is inherently wrong
does does god teach us about this
ethical value it's out there in the
world or
does murder become wrong simply because
god said so
so these two ways of looking into rules
commandments and in islam one theology
is spearheaded by the mutezula school
but also it had an impact on the
maturity theology which is in mainstream
sunni islam which i sympathize with they
said
the commandments of god are educating us
about values which are also there
inherently
out there in the world and also knowable
by reason in other words
even if there was no revelation human
could figure out that theft or murder
are wrong but because of human passions
and human you know tendency to forget
god is educating and reminding us about
those values and there are a lot of
reasons in the
in the quran to think like that
the other school the asharite said
no
these things are right and wrong simply
because god said so therefore if god
said murder is good murder would be good
so the the commandments define
everything that is ethical and this was
this is the asharite theology and i in
my book i show how these discussions
took place and what were the nuances
ashore theology became more influential
in sunni islam and i i'm critical of
that because i think if we say
god's commandments only have value in
themselves first of all we are turning
god into a capricious arbitrary
legislator right things become right and
wrong only because he says so they're
not it's not like like he is
looking into the world and seeing com
and with compassion seeing that ordinary
people i mean innocent people should not
die yeah well you could secularize that
you could secularize that argument by
asking yourself as a secular person
these fundamental laws that we have like
we sh we should not murder
do they reflect some underlying reality
in some sen in some profound sense or
are they arbitrary constructions of a
particular time and place
and it's a it's a it's a very difficult
argument to walk through
um
because it it
it always depends in some sense on what
you're aiming at right if you're aiming
at power and conquest well then maybe
murder is just just what you need but if
you're aiming at peace well maybe that's
not the right route
exactly and actually i mean the secular
way of looking at this is that for
example should governments legislate
according to what they think is right
and their commandment their laws define
everything or should there be values
beyond the governments that they should
honor right right like well that's a
natural right argument in some sense
right which is exactly foundational in
the west and less so in the french
system i would say very english common
law system
which that's why i i believe uh the
right view in islam was the natural
right argument which what the muta zela
said and the maturities also in the
sunni tradition pretty much came close
the the other one is called divine
positivism like god says whatever he
says and we just obey it without asking
why and how i mean it got more
sophisticated over time still i mean the
ashrae scholars look into the purposes
of god try to figure out so they that
allowed analogy but ultimately this
divine command theory that god posits
as he wills
legislates as he wills and this had two
consequences one is
one means that people you who don't have
your religious tradition cannot have any
value because all value comes from
divine commandments so people who are
secular people who are beyond uh
right you you close yourself to the
ethical reality out there in the world
all the ethical traditions and reasoning
second and you deny an essential
commonality between the tribes of
mankind exactly and you put yourself in
a permanent state of war exactly that's
why i call it the loss of universalism
because i mean early muslims studied
aristotle and his ethical philosophy
because aristotle is an infidel from an
islamic point of view but they saw value
because they said god gave humanity and
ethical intuition and reason and reason
is universal that allowed them so that
was the universalistic path but the
other path actually closed uh ethical
thinking that's why after that first you
can also see how it would foster a kind
of totalitarianism because if god's
commandments are what define good and
evil but i'm interpreting them exactly
then then there isn't anything beyond my
interpretation in some sense as long as
i'm correct whereas with the more
universalist view it's like well wait a
second there's something outside of this
that i'm not intelligent enough wise
enough to understand that i have to be
mindful of so let me let me take it in
that direction for a sec so i'll tell
you something i've been thinking about
i'm writing this book now called we who
wrestle with god and i'm i'm i'm really
trying to work out this the
the natural right issue in relationship
to free speech and i'm trying to do that
as a clinician and so
one of the things that carl rogers
proposed um and he was
extraordinarily influenced by
protestantism he was a seminar and he
wanted to be an evangelist before he
became a secular humanist but
rogers observed that if you listen to
people talk if you actually listened
that they would spontaneously transform
themselves in a way that improved their
life
and he pointed to a fundamental
psychological mechanism that was driving
that you you could think about it in
some sense as exactly the same thing
that a parent does when that parent
attends very carefully to their children
so that attention facilitates well i
would say in some sense the
manifestation of the healing word and i
mean that as a clinician now freud
rogers took a page from freud because
freud also observed that if you just let
people talk but you listened
that they would unwind themselves and
and straighten themselves out and and
this isn't such a preposterous
suggestion unless you believe that
speech is somehow divorced from
neurological integrity let's say or
social integrity and so
i think there's a very real sense in
which
the
the reason that free speech is a natural
right and maybe the the highest of
natural rights is because it is
precisely reflective of the mechanism by
which we move from the stagnation of our
dead thoughts into a future that's
what
better than the dead past and so any
society that interferes with that will
degenerate into a kind of totalitarian
absolutism and that becomes
indistinguishable from hell
it does i mean
very interesting i mean what you said
reminds me of a quranic verse it defines
believers as those people who listen to
the word and and follow the most
beautiful of that
to be able to do that you have to listen
first and right you have to be able to
choose that exactly uh it's a verse in
the quran i can't remember the number
now but i can send you later the number
of it uh it's a great verse that's a
great idea because you know it also it
also touches on the notion of a profound
intuition of beauty and the idea that
beauty is an intimation of what's what
is divine
and divine is deep and profound and
necessary and i don't care if you speak
about that in secular religious terms it
boils down to the same thing in the
final analysis and to use
i i talked with one of canada's great
journalists recently this man named rex
murphy who's a real national treasure
and he's so poetic and he's a deep
admirer of poetry but also a very
practical and down-to-earth person but
his words are beautiful and and part of
the reason they have such force is
because he is in communion with that
beauty and and it shines through
everything he does so these are
non-trivial realities that are being
pointed to we ignore them at our apparel
exactly and and
that is a universalistic outlook to
listen to and learn from everything and
it was there right at the beginning of
the islamic civilization and that's why
muslims
built the house of wisdom and bagged
that and translated all greek philosophy
into arabic you know which ultimately
made its way to europe through through
spain muslim spain
uh so there was this hunger to learn and
appreciate but that gradually narrowed
down
and why and it's a fact that it has down
it does happen why it happened how it
happened there are a lot of theories
about it you know what happens all the
time it happens happens all the time
it's it's it's a huge existential
reality for that to happen i think it
will happen to any civilization at the
moment they say we have reached
perfection right we don't need to learn
anything from the outside world and i
see that sort of trend in the western
civil war yeah that's the tower of babel
that's the tower of babel right you
build a structure and you think it's
reached the heights of god and as soon
as you think that everyone fragments and
speaks a different language and
everything descends and then the next
story is the flood and that's not a
bloody accident
disintegration exactly so
by reason i am referring to this view
universalistic view in early islam which
believe that morality is universal
ethics are universal the quran reminds
us and educates us indicates i mean
according to
abdul-jabbar he said the sharia
indicates what's right and wrong the
other group said the sharia constitutes
what is right and wrong so if the sharia
constitutes it you don't have to
interpret my interpretation of the quran
is what defines well you can't have that
statement without that implicit belief
behind it that's the problem with that
kind of idea it's like well it contains
the absolute truth well
through whose lens well mine well that's
pretty damn convenient for you isn't it
yeah yeah exactly and of course thinking
like that had political advantages and
actually that's an argument i made in
the book and but that narrowed islamic
thinking it also led to literalism i
mean blind literalism because if you
don't have except values outside of the
written text
you ultimately
become less
willing to interpret the text and move
away a little bit from the text because
you're bound with it too much and and
that is that literalism is a burning
problem i think in islamic jurisprudence
today i mean a lot of the issues about
women's rights in the muslim world come
from illiteracy it's also a terrible
technical problem right which the
postmodernists grappled with and which
in some sense defeated them it's because
when you read a book
you say well is the truth is in a single
word or is it in a phrase but the phrase
is in the sentence and the sentence
changes the phrase and then the sentence
is in a paragraph and then you know
there's a really interesting image
online showing the hyperlink nature of
the bible which verses refer to which
other it looks like a kind of a rainbow
the bible is densely hyperlinked because
all of it refers to
it it all refers to other parts of
itself which is part of its depth but
what that means is that
while you need the whole thing to
interpret each word you need every
paragraph to interpret each sentence and
so how do you know if your
interpretation is correct well we we
believe what the sentence says it's like
nope sorry that's just not going to do
and and what do you mean by literally
true ex and are you so sure that literal
truth is the mo is the deepest form of
truth because i don't think it is
there's fictional truth
and and what that's deeper than literal
truth obviously
so
there's certainly uh
and we have that in islam the
interpretation of the quran by the quran
so you read it's surah 2 something and
you read 57 something else and they
actually explain each other that's a
very powerful approach
biliteralism i mean i can give you one
example of women's rights for example
like which is of course a burning issue
in certain parts of not all but certain
parts of the muslim world today you may
have heard that you know saudi
authorities didn't allow women to drive
cars for a long time and finally when it
was allowed you know it was a big reform
and the autocratic prince who did that
you know got a lot of brony points in
the west although it was probably a
bigger reform than was even wrecked it
was it wasn't
for them but the people who demanded
were jailed so it's a it's a weird
autocratic form of reform but then now
pakistan i mean not sorry in afghanistan
the taliban came to power in the 90s
they were not allowing women to even
walk on the street but now they will say
we will allow that
okay that's the progress for taliban but
still women will not be able to travel
alone so there is this issue of woman
traveling alone with a male guardian i
mean it will come up in all these
islamic issues i mean to conservative
islamic interpretations now where does
it come from well it comes from a few
hadiths that are sayings reported from
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
and it's in sahih buhari one of the most
authoritative the most authoritative i
think collection of hadith sources
although i would still have some
questions there on
on certain texts but anyway there you
read prophet muhammad saying
a woman a muslim woman should not
travel alone without a machere that's a
male guardian
for longer than a distance of three days
another version is a distance of one day
so that's there that's the text and
classical scholars you know of course
they thought this is important they
calculated actually what's the
difference of three days oh 78 miles or
57 miles there are different versions of
that so women should not be able to go
and still today like in the uk if you
ask a fatwa from a conservative scholars
they can say can a woman go between
birmingham and london they can measure
the distance they say no no it's not
it's not more than that distance well
that is a textualist reading of this now
another reading which is promoted by
turkish scholars and others i'm sure is
that well prophet muhammad said so
probably because in seventh century
arabia in the desert between mecca and
medina there were bad bandits attacking
every unprotected woman so a woman
walking alone without a male guardian
and and woman didn't carry swords by
this i mean only men could protect women
would be attacked by these people so he
said something obviously related to that
context so his security his issue was
security so security is a universal
value we should care about but if you
today worry about the security of a
woman driving between mecca and medina
make sure she wears a seat belt right i
mean it's a different
the right of a woman to walk
unaccompanied
which is obviously a right that should
not be trammelled is dependent to no
small degree on the fact that she can do
so in relative safety and that's
forgotten in some sense right i mean i'm
not saying that that right shouldn't be
promoted or doesn't exist i'm saying
that
the conditions that currently prevail in
the west i mean when i lived in montreal
for example anyone pretty much could go
anywhere at any time of day and be safe
well that's a hell of an accomplishment
that that's the case and that is not the
historical norm by any stretch of the
imagination
so that's for sure i mean these
religious commandments
even the quran and prophet muhammad's
commandments as a muslim i value i
respect all of them but i understand
that they were issued in a certain
context they were given they were
altered in a certain context and when
you understand the intention behind that
you begin to understand the sharia more
intention based called makassett in
islamic tradition so that's one way of
going forward in islamic tradition that
scholars are thinking
and i understand like corporal
punishment i mean that's one of the
issues that come up very much with islam
i mean
why you know why are there corporal
punishments in the quran and in the
prophet's commandments well why are they
in the old testament too right i mean on
all these texts you have corporal
punishment yes an eye for an eye and a
tooth for a tooth was a marked
improvement over the previous
arrangement
exactly and and the quran says there is
a life for you in casas which is
retaliation because in before the quran
arabs were killing each other in drones
and you know tribes were fighting each
other and by the way there was no
individual responsibility so anybody
from the other tribe would be given you
know as as a as a retaliation so but the
quran brought the idea of retaliation
with individual responsibility
and also it brought a few uh corporal
punishments like amputation of hands for
theft for example which is one of the
most controversial issues i think about
islamic law in the world today now one
the littlest way to understand it is
that while god says this so you will
implement it as as the way it is or you
know you will find to you know find some
modifications around it but another way
of looking at it is
well there's a very good reason why i
gave corporal punishment in seventh
century early seventh century arabia
because there were no prisons
i mean prison is an institution that is
built by a state and you need to build
brick walls and you need to feed
somebody inside and you need to have a
guard i mean 7th century early 17th
century mecca and medina weren't
anything like that people people could
only punish crime instantly or let them
go i mean there was no idea and that's
why pre-islamic arabs were also
amputated
or killed and risk a feud
exactly and that's why pre-islamic arabs
were also amputated hands for theft so
the quran legislated in that context and
as a muslim i believe it legislated for
justice it legislated for the right
moral purposes
but today we can punish theft with other
means such as you know prison sentences
or fines which the ottomans already did
i mean these modifications have already
taken place to a certain extent in the
muslim world i'm saying these things
because i mean this kind of literalist
understanding of islamic things we can't
let the literalists get away with the
notion that their understanding of a
sentence is right
that just isn't how a text works it's
way more complicated than that and
that's a big problem because it opens up
the specter of infinite interpretations
which is the postmodernist dilemma
but
but saying the text has no meaning or
any meaning is no solution to that it's
like saying life has any meaning or no
meaning it's a problem especially when
they say their understanding is right
and they have the right to dominate the
state and they have to impose that on
everybody else right that's right that's
a key problem we have
in in the islamist movements let's talk
about mary for a minute oh yeah sure all
right yeah well because this issue
yeah well this issue of women's rights
is definitely worth touching on now so
so
why do you think mary is represented so
uh what would you say why does she have
this privileged representation in the
quran and what does that mean as far as
you've been able to determine
well very good question very interesting
i should also add that the most
prominent figure in the whole quran the
most prominent human being is moses you
know followed by probably mary and
abraham and then come jesus christ you
know he's also of course narrated
because the quran is
educating prophet muhammad
about his predecessors like these were
the pious people before you these are
the people your your forbearers i mean
you should follow the footsteps of moses
you should be like jesus and and mary is
narrated because he's so high up and
revered in the islamic tradition she's
praised for her chastity
and she's praised for
uh being brave
because the fact that i mean she was of
course accused for committing adultery
i mean that's what the quran says
because she had a child without a father
and and we we hear that actually we see
that in the quran and she uh she goes
and the quranic birth story is different
than the
gospels in the gospels you know mary
gives birth in
in bethlehem and as stable and you know
that's the christian imagery the chordic
story is different she goes and gives
birth on in the wilderness out of
nowhere
and under palm tree
because she's afraid that you know
people will blame her and people do
blame her after that and then under this
palm tree she gives birth to jesus and
she's afraid but god comforts her and
angels speak to her
now i think
the story there the archetype there is a
woman who will be unjustly blamed for
committing adultery already she didn't
do
and that's a deem that comes up also in
the quran for another woman who's not
named but we know it's aisha prophet
muhammad's wife
in the 24th chapter of the quran
prophet muhammad's wife i mean that's we
know from postcarding sources but she
was left alone in the desert a man had
given her a ride with her with his camel
when she came back to the city there was
a rumor that maybe something happened
between them and prophet muhammed was
devastated aisha was devastated it was a
very stressful moment and then the court
and then the koran
legislated about that condemned the lie
and the libels
and said if you will bring any
accusation against a woman of adultery
you should bring four witnesses
to before you blame her and of course
there was no witness in this case
so these two stories i'm reading them
together like it's about protecting
women from accusation of adultery which
was of course the worst thing you could
do it to a woman especially in the
pre-modern era even today i think
in many societies so mary is highlighted
in that sense which is very interesting
uh by the way it's interesting though
and sad that the quranic injunction to
protect women by asking for four
witnesses
was misabused in pakistan to actually
abuse women i mean it was was used
because when you don't understand the
intention this is what happens there has
been cases in pakistan of a woman being
raped raped in a village
getting pregnant
and she goes to
she's taken to a uh sharia court in the
in the rural areas and they ask where
are your four witnesses she says i don't
have four witnesses but the fact that
she's pregnant
proves that she committed adultery
although she's raped and she there has
been a few cases like that who were
given the death penalty by the court
although it was later overturned luckily
by the constitutional court so i'm just
saying this to if you don't understand
what guy what god legislated with what
intention and if you blindly bring a a
law into another different context
without understanding the understanding
the difference between rape and adultery
also it can have disastrous consequences
but sorry we digress so mary is highly
praised
some of the things said in the quran
about mary you cannot find them in the
gospels
but you can find them somewhere else you
can find them in the uh
in the gospel of james which is an
apocryphal gospel protagonium of james
because there were these eastern gospels
which told about the childhood of mary
and childhood of jesus which are not
gnostic gospels yeah gnostic or other
ones
and so the koran strongly resonates with
that and i think one reason how do you
account for that historically
i mean was there an influence of james
mode of thinking on muhammad or what
what do you think's happening there well
i wrote a book
i know you did i know he says yes no
it's a great question i appreciate it
well how do i account that i mean
islam certainly continues
judeo-christian traditions and very
strongly resonates by a little known
christian strain known as jewish
christianity i mean which which comes
from which considered james as their
saint you know patron saint jewish
christians which we know from the church
fathers called ebionites people called
or nazarenes
they were practicing jews who accepted
christ as the messiah but as the jewish
messiah
not in the fully christian sense of the
term not divine but as jews
expect the messiah today so they were
practicing jews who accepted jesus which
made them
unorthodox from both a jewish point of
view and also a mainstream christian
point of view not the wisest political
move maybe yeah so that's why i mean
they were squeezed in uh we hear them as
heresies in church father's writings and
they disappeared after fourth century
but what is striking is that
the jesus defined by the quran
is very similar to what the jewish
christians believed
and also the theology of quran is very
similar to this idea that you're saved
by acts not just faith alone which is
you know a this is not a thorny line
yeah and uh i think it's more on a
jewish path but appreciates jesus from a
more jewish perspective
uh and it is very similar now there are
two ways to understand this one is to
say
well some of these teachings made their
way to arabia and you know obviously
influenced the birth of islam and
prophet muhammad might have acquired
these teachings from these
christian unorthodox groups that's the
historical interpretation and and i can
understand how uh people think like that
as a muslim i believe well this is
revelation i mean god sent that
revelation god sent this revelation
again so i don't need to believe that
prophet muhammad acquired that wisdom
from a pre-existing community but that's
a that's an answer of faith
others can i can very easily understand
that they can say these christian
teachings influence the birth of islam
but whatever path we take even if we
believe that there's revelation or even
if we believe that there's a history the
point is our religious traditions are
deeply connected and and they are not
alien and and there is not a
judeo-christian tradition but
judeo-christo islamic tradition as i
said and the moment we begin to connect
them we will
learn we can learn from each other i
think muslims can learn from christian
tradition more and christians can learn
certain things from the islamic
tradition today
and we can think of our problems as we
the monotheists you know we have these
issues and how do we deal with them in
the modern world
that's why i find intra-christian
discussions about freedom or freedom of
conscience or secular state very
interesting
and i think we have
we have patterns and roots in islam
which can be connected to those
okay i want to torture you with one more
issue and and then we should probably
stop because i'm getting i'm getting
worn out listening and talking so
um so it might stop making sense no it's
per it's good it's not a bad thing it's
a good thing
so
i mentioned earlier this idea that
rogers developed that was deeply
influenced by his protestantism and that
had also been observed by freud and the
psychoanalysts that merely letting
people
speak
but in a welcoming way right in in in an
attentive way so you're providing a
container for the revelation let's say
the revelation of themselves to
themselves that that was intrinsically
deeply healing and one of the things
that jung
pointed out which i thought was
staggering in its implications was that
the mythological or theological christ
was actually a symbolic representation
of that process
yes so it's quite so imagine there's a
historical figure but there's a there's
a psychological figure that's how i
would look at it but a theolo you can
think about it in theological terms at
all this gets complicated when you get
into the outer reaches of thought
but then
so what i see happening was that the
west organized itself unbeknownst to
itself to some degree under this
principle
that
free discourse accompanied by attentive
listening which is something like care
for the other person's self-revelation
and belief that that will make the world
a better place in the highest sense and
it's sort of the science
of of successful therapy in my
estimation
well that's that's
that's
both embodied and symbolized by the
figure of christ
and you can see that as a reflection of
human universalism as well
he happens to be the figure in the west
when you're speaking psychologically but
it's representing something that's a lot
more like john's notion of the eternal
word
and and something that the egyptians
tried to represent with the figure of
horus and the mesopotamians with the
figure of marduk and so forth and it's
sort of at the basis of the campbell
jung idea of a universal archetypal
redemption story and so
what i
what i struggle with is in the islam
world you have this contradiction in
some sense
from my perspective as a westerner
between the figure of muhammad as
in some ways the ultimate authority or
guide or
or prophet and the figure of christ and
i can't understand it psychologically
it's like
because i can't distinguish between
the
honor given christ in islam and the
honor given muhammad there's a
contradiction there that i can't think
my way through
uh well great question
i think there is no contradiction from
an islamic point of view because islam
sees this as one big history of
monotheism so prophet muhammad is
following the footsteps of
moses or abraham or
isaac or jacob or noah and christ is put
in that
path so that's why christ isn't divine
but he is he is a word from god he's
revelation so he's actually
metaphysically speaking the statements
about jesus puts him about any other
actually creature uh
besides the angels when you look at from
a quranic point of view but the quran
still insists that he's not divine so
and there is no paulian theology of him
you know being dying for the sins of
humanity so there's there's not that so
that's why
christ is brought to the broader
abrahamic story which doesn't culminate
only with christ but continues with with
muhammad so that's why i mean islam
takes the lower christology i mean if
you will from it
so that's why i think it makes sense
although
uh i think enough attention maybe has
not been given an islamic thought to the
story of christ that has narrated us to
us in the new testament
uh
in in early islamic history actually you
see that muslims were studying the bible
called israelite i mean the jewish and
christian sources because the quran
refers to them so go and learn more from
resources and i think that was a
valuable
flocks of information and wisdom into
islam later it was seen as oh no no we
don't need them we just need our own you
know trajectory and so the loss of
universalism was not just loss of greek
philosophy but maybe even more so
this you know the matrix between the
quran and bible that's why i'm also
calling on fellow muslims to study the
new testament and learn about the story
of christ there are passages in the new
testament especially paulian letters
that will not go well with muslim
theology but we can still read and learn
at least the history
of christ and that is one
actually that's why that's what brought
me to
writing an article in the new york times
a few years ago what jesus can teach
muslims today
because
besides all the theological issues about
his nature like
that's that's a matter of theology but
christ had a role in first century
judaism
when jews were in a crisis like we
muslims today i mean that analogy was
made by arnold toynbee he said muslims
of the modern era are like first century
jews in the sense that there is a
powerful civilization rome that is
coming on to you
and you have you have herodians who you
know ally with that you know become
imitating of that and you have the
zealots you know become fanatic and and
and
toybe made a knowledge and i think
that's very uh very apt for us
i see christ as a third vey i mean he
was not a collaborator of rome but he
wasn't a fanatic he was not a guerrilla
leader fighting a battle against them
and and he called on his fellow jews to
rediscover their own values let's look
at bakar halaka and see the intention
and his criticism of dry literalism
and sometimes arrogant piety you know
you take pride you look down upon other
people saying that they are sinners but
um i'm pious they are so relevant to
some of the problems we have in the
muslim world today i mean and in the
western world in the western world too
and i think that's why
that's why i mean i uh as a monotheist
you know walking on the
abrahamic path and being a muslim
alhamdulillah as we say i believe
the broader
tradition of monotheism that's includes
moses of course but the story of christ
in particular there's a lot to teach us
and muhammad abdul made this point i
mean he was a muslim reformer in the
late 19th century and he said actually
muslims believe in the second coming of
christ i mean it's there it's an art
article of faith in sunni islam he says
the second coming of christ means we
will begin to look at the sharia as he
looked at the law look at the intentions
you know look at the this is the moral
wisdom behind that and just don't turn
into a dry set of laws
we just you know implement without you
know thinking of the consequences i
think there is such deep wisdom there in
the in the christian tradition which is
important for us muslims there are a lot
of
i mean wisdom in the muslim tradition
too i think to share with the world but
we could use some more wisdom couldn't
we yeah i mean one thing i mean like i
see
people becoming so obsessed with race in
the western world since i came to
america a few years ago i mean people
speak about all the colors skin colors
up there and i understand that there's a
history behind that there's a of course
persecution and yeah just a termination
of babel
but
i mean one thing we can say proudly as
muslim is that well we never had that
islam is a color blind religion and you
know who was fascinated by that malcolm
x
he was of course a leader in the uh
african-american community he was
because of the persecution and
discrimination he had also a very
negative view of the white people
but his life changed when he went to
mecca and that's a very powerful story
and he saw muslims with blue eyes and
blonde hair and black skin and brown
skin and he said they're all brothers in
faith they're not discriminating against
each other so he became post you know
racial
thanks to his exposure to that
universalism in islam which i'm proud of
as a muslim so i think there are great
things in our traditions to share with
each other but we have to overcome the
totalitarian impulse as you said the
coercive interpretations the hateful
interpretations
and uh there's
there is ground to work in every
tradition and i i'm trying to do my part
as a you know muslim living in the 21st
century is concerned about the
future of the world and the umma
much appreciated
thank you very much for talking to me
this was a great conversation where are
you
i'm in washington dc right now you're in
washington yeah at the cato institute
offices well it would be nice to see you
if i i'm going to come to washington
next year and it would be very nice to
see you oh inshallah as we say i would
love to uh let's break bread together
and and speak about all these great uh
issues which we should all think about
thanks a lot thank you thank you very
much
[Music]
you